hello everyone and welcome to round
three of this year's video World Cup we
have a very nice game between two
Norwegian friends Ari antaria and Magnus
Carlsen and it's uh it's a pretty crazy
game that features a line that both
Players missed it's uh sort of what I
like to call a disgusting Engine line
Because unless you like unless you have
a soul of silicon you do not see stuff
like this so it's gonna be a really fun
pause the video moment for you guys and
yeah basically we are continuing uh the
the journey here uh one of the pretty
much the only tournament Magnus Carlsen
never won is the video World Cup okay he
didn't win the official World random uh
Championship but I guess you could
consider that not strictly chess uh but
yeah affiliate World Cup is definitely
something that he would like to add to
his belt and he he played it a few times
he played it as at the age of 13 and he
even did incredibly well it was in 2005
and he um uh got to the to the final 16
he he uh won all the way through the
through to round four where he was
eliminated by Evgeni barev and then he
played in 2017. we've covered that game
if you guys remember against boujong ji
he lost to him in round three he was a
pretty pretty incredible game and then
in 2021 uh Magnus got all the way to the
semi-finals he faced yankeesht of Duda
and Duda eliminated magnets from the
World Cup now Magnus will try again and
this time his opponent in a round two of
their match first game was won by Magnus
it was a pretty pretty drawish end game
but Magnus kept grinding kept the
grinding kept it grinding and in the end
he ground him down and now tari needs to
play for the win with the white pieces
and he plays a most deadly line the
sharpest of lines it's called the
bayonet attack I'm sure you guys have
seen it I've shown it a couple times on
the channel it's a wonderful wonderful
attempt but if you know your stuff with
black it's very hard to press for the
win whatever however uh the win does
present itself in this game but it's uh
like I said you really have to find this
one so let's check it out Daddy has the
white pieces and he opens with Pawn to
E4
uh if my Pawn ever moves we have Pawn to
C6 by Magnus D4 and now Pawn to D5 the
karokan defenses on the board we have E5
and now Bishop to F5 and now Pawn to G4
this is the bayonet attack and the black
has a couple of options here he could go
back Bishop to D7 he will Bishop to G60
Google Bishop D4 and of course if you
play this you have to know all of the
replies which of course study does he we
have Bishop T4 by Magnus Pawn to F3 and
now Bishop to G6 and now the move that
uh where you look for for an opportunity
Pawn to E6 now this is I've actually uh
faced an opponent once in the Croatian
league and uh I saw that he played this
with the black pieces and he was rated
maybe maybe 2250 2300 and I prepared
this Pawn to E6 line uh I got a great
position but uh he in the end he just uh
defeated me because he just knew that
how to play the positions much better
than than I did even though I was the
one who surprised him in the opening uh
but okay we have uh uh Queen uh Queen to
D6 another movie is of course F
characters on E6 and uh then you go into
some like Pawn to H4 then Pawn to C5
then Pawn to H5 Bishop to F7 and let's
say Pawn to F4 Knights the C6 and Knight
to F3 and okay it's a it's a fine
position but you you're really forcing
things and it's not um not a great black
will black will not have problem playing
this so uh well you could could tried a
queen to D6 is considered much safer he
captures an F7 Bishop characters and now
Knight the C3 we have Knight to D7 by
Magnus uh Pawn to F4 and now Pawn to H5
we have Pawn to G5 and Ponte E6 now
Knight to F3 uh and here there is a game
where H4 was played right away gobblepop
had this position with the white against
benzekorpa last year in in Budapest in
Hungary uh but that game uh ended uh
very poorly for black umra pop won that
game but here we have Knights the E7 by
Magnus and it is now as of movie 11 that
we have a completely new game a lot of
pieces around that black king but if
they are doing their job properly you
know it will be very good for him so
Bishop to D3 and now Pawn to H4 by
Magnus we have Castles by tari and the
bishop to H5 incredible how this bishop
just comes back into the game becomes uh
Fully Alive and now is again pinning
this Knight we have Queen to E1 now
putting pressure on that H4 Pawn also
I'm painting from The Bishop's grasp and
now Pawn to G6 by Magnus and here the
problem is if you play Knight captures
in H4 it's a free Pawn you can take it
the engine probably does take it but
then Magnus castles Queen side and what
you've done is that you have castles on
opposite sides of the board and you give
magnus's Rook the semi-open H file so
does it doesn't look like you know a
dream come true exactly so Knights the
E5 was played and now we have Bishop to
G7 Bishop to D2 Atari just continuous
development now you have to figure out
how to go for that black king how to how
to uh you know cross F5 if Magnus goes
Queen side how do you advance on the
queen side it's not easy to do these
things so here we have Knight to F5 by
Magnus and now Knight to A4 now one
thing that you have to be very very
careful about is that if you play C3 and
you kind of want to play C3 because the
D4 Pawn uh is hanging in in some of the
lines uh you you could trap your knight
with Ponta B5 uh if okay you do have
Knight to C5 at this point but you know
you have to be very careful but that's
actually a good question why is tari
offering the D4 Pawn well if Magnus
captures it it looks like uh again it
looks like it's the dream you eliminated
the Central Pawn uh how his wife to
react to this well the the point is
Knight captures on these seven Queen
captures and now just C3 and white has
full control now the D4 Knight has to
move the D4 square is no longer
available uh for the bishop in the
future and if Knight to F5 you can go
Knight to C5 now attacking the queen and
there's a double attack on the E6 Pawn
and the white is definitely now
in white no longer has to worry about
being worse or anything it's definitely
white who will be pushing for the win
here so Magnus of course does not do
that he plays Bishop captures on E5 F
captures on E5 attacks the queen queen
E7 and now Bishop captures an F5 uh
Atari eliminates this Knight as okay the
D4 Pawn uh could be a problem but you
you can't really I mean a C3 just B5 and
it's a really really bad position for
white so here Tata decides for Bishop
captures on F5 G captures on F5 and now
Pawn to H3 and now while Magnus could
play something like castles and I mean
it's something that we all would play
Magnus plays King the F7 this is how he
wants to get the Rook into the game and
he doesn't mind his King being on the
same file as tari's Rook that's okay
King to H2 we have quanta B6 now
stopping Knight to C5 and also preparing
a C5 and 30 of course stops IT Pawn to
B4 and it is one the strongest moves
recommended by the engine as it usually
is Knight to f8 and now Knight back to
B2 we have Pawn to C5 by Magnus now B
captures B captures and Knight to D3
putting pressure on that C5 pawn and
here uh you you have to play a move that
is uh sort of sort of a move that you
don't want to play and that movie Spawn
characters on D4 this will double your
pawns and it doesn't look like a very
useful move however this is the move you
have to play however Magnus played Pawn
to C4 uh he grabbed more space he
Advanced upon he forces the Knight to
move and now the position is uh well if
you go really really deeply the position
is just lost for Magnus so feel free to
pause the video and try to spot this
incredible move while I give you a
couple of seconds
foreign
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on finding a move
that even the engine doesn't find at
lower depths and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is Pawn
to G6 with check this is uh with the
move that tari missed had he found this
he probably would have won the game
because once you know this move is there
of course you find all the other moves
uh but yeah it's a it's a really a crazy
move to play now how how would you react
to this obviously the pawn has to be
captured you can't just allow the pawn
to stay there Knight captures on G6 and
now you bring the Knight to C5 so it's
very important to open up the G file for
the attack and now after something like
let's say rotate the B8 you will play
Queen to C1 now you will bring your
Bishop to G5 and then you will control
this diagonal your knight is beautifully
placed on C5 and to give you an example
of what could happen let's say Rook the
B5 Bishop to G5 attacks the queen queen
has to move now comes Bishop to F6
attacks The Rook Rook move somewhere uh
Queen to E3 and now let's say queen to
B6 and book to F2 adding another
Defender and also preparing to bring the
A1 Rook into the game Bishop to G5 uh
sorry upon the F4 and now or you don't
have to play Pawn to F4 but the engine
says that you you have to Bishop to G5
you will now eliminate this Pawn because
it is pinned and now King the E8 with
Bishop captures on F4 Knight to E7 and
now Rook to G1 it's a very very long
line but I I gave the engine time to
Crunch the numbers Rook to F7 and now
Rook F to G2 and uh it's very very hard
or rather impossible for black to defend
Rook captures on C5 the captures on C5
Queen to B4 and now Pawn to C3 even we
have Queen to A4 and now Queen to F2 uh
King to D7 and now you go in for the
kill queen characters and H4 uh Bishop
to F3 but now just Pawn to C6 with check
King captures and now Rook to F2 and
that's it Bishop D4 you will play Queen
to H5 attack The Rook once The Rook
moves you will attack jacket again and
now connect with the pawn on E6 and
There Is No Escape now something will
fall once the queen captures an E6 uh
happens then it's just uh it's just game
over the king hunt will reach um uh you
know
it's its end uh so that's what you
should have done here after this Pawn to
see for move but tari missed it he
didn't think that Magnus would allow
such a thing if it was possible he
trusted him a bit too much and he played
Knight to F4 and now okay Magnus played
Knight to G6 and he gives him one more
chance not to get a better position but
to get a playable position however here
tari has to play Knight captures on D5
he didn't he played Knight captures on
G6 but just to give you an example of
what happens here captures captures and
Rook captures on F5 checks or two pawns
for the piece and also for the attack
King the G8 you also go after the queen
with Bishop to B4 after the queen moves
now you put the bishop on D6 and it's a
very very nice position you can bring
the Rook into the game you you can bring
the Rook to F6 the bishop here really
controls everything you have the past E
Pawn uh white white is definitely the
one who will be playing for the win here
but tari didn't do it tari just played
Knight captures on G6 King captures and
now he played Queen to E3 uh Rook H to
B8 by Magnus Rook 8 to B1 and now Rook
to B6 Magnus just offers a trade here he
will double up on the B file Queen to C3
and now Queen to B7 doubling up here uh
tari trades with captures captures and
Bishop to C1 and he was in this position
on move 32 that the players agreed to a
draw as there is nothing more to be done
here there is no way for tari to break
through and now it's definitely Magnus
who is better here he can play some like
a five Queen before he can play Queen to
B1 as The Rook on F1 is undefended then
bring the Rook into the game so that he
can only lose this game from going uh
four sorry forward but Magnus of course
it doesn't want to risk uh you know
pushing for the win for for no reason as
he already he really wants to win the
World Cup this time so a draw in this
game means a victory in the match and
that is enough for him but yeah you
can't break through here the pawns are
just uh uh unmovable you you can't pass
your own G5 Pawn also one of the reasons
why it was really important to sacrifice
this G Pawn just to open up lines of
attack towards the black king uh and
yeah they just uh drew the game game
here but after they spawn to C4 yeah I
mean a very crazy stuff like this uh
this is uh the strongest because the
Knight can no longer come to C5 once you
do this then Knight to C5 it's not scary
in itself but once you combine it with
G6 and all of these lines of attack
towards the black king open up and
Knight comes to C5 then it's incredibly
incredibly dangerous but yeah I thought
he missed it he didn't go for it and the
Magnus wins the match he goes into the
next round uh we don't have the pairings
of round five just yet I know that
Magnus Carlsen will be facing Vincent
kaimer in round four so uh there's that
okay let me just uh check real quickly
maybe some of the other pairs have been
decided so I don't wanna
uh misinform you guys now let me just
check ever since chess.com bought chest
24 it's it's loading time has like
quadrupled so okay uh camera will be
facing Carlson we decided that we
decided that rasmusvane is uh in round
four but no opponent also now upon
Google defeated Narayanan and he is now
very very close to overtaking anishagiri
and Wesley so in the in the uh world top
10 we'll see if he will be able to do
that Daniel vocaturo eliminated Daniel
dubov uh he won a very nice game one and
then he drew game two also we don't know
who his opponent will be Ray Robson
still waiting for his opponent and I
think the last one is Alexis Arana also
waiting for his opponent Arjun erigasi
will be facing Java kirsinderov that
will truly be uh you know a contest to
to recommend uh and the last player uh
is Hikaru Nakamura who is still waiting
for his opponent well there you have it
you've been nicely informed on the on
the happenings of round four very nice
done by Magnus too bad portari Magnus
gave him a chance he didn't play it um
and yeah it's kind of kind of the theme
of the bayonet attack uh you know at
least the what I uh the little work that
I've done you know that at some point
early on you will have E6 maybe later on
you will have G6 probably so you know in
case you you guys play this you know
always look for E6 and G6 breakthroughs
it just might be the difference between
a win and a draw uh once again really
hope you guys enjoyed it I would like to
thank schlerture Paul Harris Samuel Kane
Aaron is the best wife and no Laura is
the best wife for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the video
World Cup until it finishes uh thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day